keep Pompeii these 76ers reporter for
philly.com he joins us Keith good
morning thanks for joining us House
morale in Philadelphia today it's crazy
I mean everyone is excited but thanks
for having me on on the show
give me an update on Joelle embiid well
you know Joelle the hope is that Joelle
plays in the first you know the first
round series I think that that's a great
possibility he doesn't think that he'll
be able to go in the first game you know
right now he says his you know his eye
before the orbital bone isn't 100%
healed and it's extremely numb that the
thing the concern that the Sixers have
is you know you don't want it to get hit
again you know this soon and they just
want to make sure that everything is
okay because it's one of those things
where yeah he could play in the game but
since it's not a hundred percent he'll
you don't want to you know hinder his
future but um I get a sense that they
really believe that he is going to play
at some point in the first round six
there's a legitimate threat to the
Cavaliers you know are a huge unknown
and the reason why I'm saying that is
yes they are playing great and yes they
do have for veterans and Amir Johnson JJ
Redick Marko Anderson / Silva however
their young stars have yet to play in a
playoff game so there's a lot of unknown
with that but I will say that things
seem to be set up nicely for them having
the three seed you know Boston is
struggling right now so they could get
past Miami you know I don't think that
they'll have problems with Boston but
when we're talking about a serious
threat to the Cavs a team that has you
know been there before and the intensity
is going to just rise you know I don't
know if they can beat the Cavs in a
seven-game series to go to the
championship it feels like there's so
much admiration between LeBron and Ben
Simmons what do you read into anything
with that Keith
I read him that when LeBron and I'm
retired that business sentence is going
to be the she's going to be the face of
you know this agency that's what I read
it you know but no you know I think it's
one of those things where I know that
everyone is saying is LeBron want to
come to Philadelphia LeBron I want to
come here I think at the end of the day
LeBron is gonna have to do what's best
for him and you know right now he's
trying to position himself you know to
you know to of course
it'll make money win championships but
you also hear that you know LeBron is
thinking about life after basketball you
know so just because if he comes to
Philly they'll be the top team in the
East but does that help him out in
regards to life after basketball but
when you look at their relationship they
they're so close to whereas I think
LeBron wants to get the best out of Ben
so he comes at him hard and then after
Ben has great games he's like you know a
big brother would be proud of his little
little brother for playing hard and
attacking him talking to keep Pompey
covers the 76ers for philly.com how
would you summarize marquel falses year
you know incomplete because the the
reason being is you look at marquel
folks and he you know this guy came in
there was a lot of hype you know the
Sixers traded up to get him and then he
goes ahead and he misses the 68 games
you know he's back playing he's looking
better but again he's not still at the
level that he would have been if he
would have played the entire season
he knows that team knows that you know
right now he's getting his confidence
together so I will say it's incomplete
because you know right now another thing
is the great thing about marquel folks
is that when you have marquel folks
coming off the bench you basically have
a starter you know coming off the bench
and that makes the 76ers deeper but I
would have to say that when you think of
marquel folks and you have to say is
incomplete because he hasn't you know
played enough
but what I don't understand here Keith
there still seems to be this mystery
about his shoulder and what he was doing
with his shot there was nothing wrong
with his shot in college so what
happened between college getting drafted
and going to the Sixers what happened
was and I've written this I don't think
anything was ever wrong with the
shoulder I think that you know for
whatever reason marquel was going
through a tough time and he developed
the yips
you know and I think that you know the
Sixers were probably trying to protect
him and I also think that you know
within you know certain you know
dialogues you know it came to the point
well it's not my problem it must be
someone else's problem wait do you think
the Sixers made this like is this a
cover with the shoulder being hurt that
that he had the yips with his shot and
it wasn't any damage to his shoulder
well I think this is what I think would
happen I think that his shoulder was
bothering him but I kind of think that
there was more involved with that you
know I mean I think that you know if he
if you say his shoulder was sore yeah
but I've never heard of anyone having
the shoulder injury that he had who
couldn't play basketball because they
all had to relearn his nut now and I
just think that there were people
probably trying to protect him and they
you know and they came up with things
but I do not believe that the trainer
messed up his shot I do not believe that
his shoulder is the reason why he didn't
play and here's a prime example you
remember when he did that backwards shot
the length of the court and made it now
if your shoulder is bothering you you
can't do that you know the same yeah
so it's just you know again I'm not
faulting the Sixers but I just think
that people were trying to protect him
and sometimes you know it's kind of like
you know the hey like if you have a bum
knee but you also Springs your ankle but
you don't want anyone to know you have a
bum knee you say oh okay he's sitting
because of a sprained ankle mm-hmm
I'll leave you now this is Ben Simmons a
rookie yeah I mean not only that you
know I think I think I think Ben Simmons
gets a lot of criticism for being good
right but no one's talking about the
fact that this guy was a power forward
his entire life and now he's a pretty
good point guard now the thing about Ben
Simmons and this is how you can tell
he's a rookie because Ben Simmons still
has it still has to perfect it has to
perfect three throw shooting he still
doesn't shoot from the outside and those
are things once he becomes a veteran
that he'll work on a he'll develop you
know and when you hear the fact that
he's not a rookie I mean no one said
David Robertson wasn't a rookie when he
missed two years and played you know no
one says that to European players who
come over after playing five seasons
you know overseas they don't say they're
rookies I mean I don't even think anyone
was criticizing Blake Griffin when he
missed this year I think it's just
getting to a point nowadays that there's
so much on the line was getting Rookie
of the Year you know in regards to
bonuses and in regards to endorsements
and I think that you know people know
that the voters out there can control it
so they'll say hey Ben Simmons looks
great but he's not a rookie United mean
so does he still get hazed like rookies
get hazed Keith is Ben did he get hazed
this year like a rookie would I mean I
think he's a lot last year when he was
around but yeah I mean he does some
things but the thing about Ben is you
know there's a cool like calm collective
type of guy you know so he really
doesn't let a lot of things bother him
and another thing you have to realize
that you know this team is completely
different than most because you do not
have a lot of veterans on there I mean
they have more than the past but I think
you may have four guys who are five guys
who are veterans the rest of them are
all around the same age you know so the
hazing here is going to be completely
different if you were
Cleveland or Houston great stuff Keith
have fun in the playoffs we appreciate
your time thanks for having me let's
keep Pompeii covers the 76ers philly.com
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]